these guys just had their favorite event
of the year that would be the White
House correspondence association dinner
now the White House Correspondents
association dinner used to be a Kind of
a Funny event in Washington D.C
and it was when the people who were
reporting on the White House all those
journalists they would get to go and
make jokes about Washington DC and
they'd usually get a comedian to come
into the room and make fun of them and
and the president would often stop by
and make jokes about them as well and it
was all kind of funny and was fairly
self-effacing and that is over the White
House Correspondents association dinner
has now become
the Oscars
it's hard to differentiate between the
Oscars and the White House
Correspondents association dinner
because these liberal journals have have
puffed themselves up so much and
Hollywood celebrities have degraded
themselves so much they seem to have met
in the middle now and so you lose all of
the glitz and glamor and everything
aspirational that used to make the
Oscars worth watching and you also lose
the self-effacing reality that that used
to give the journals some credibility or
these were just tough guys who were
pursuing a story speaking truth to power
they were grizzled you weren't going to
get one over on them now it's red
carpets now it's photo lines now
Chrissy Teigen who I'm reliably informed
is a celebrity all I know about Chrissy
Teigen is that Candace has a fight with
her or something and they kind of make
funny videos on the internet about her
uh Chrissy Teigen was walking into the
White House correspondence association
dinner dressed to the nines I guess
undressed the nines actually she was
wearing a ton this woman had her her
servants walking behind her carrying the
rest of her gown and the scene was kind
of funny because there were a lot of
global warming protesters who were
surrounding her and the other attendees
screaming about how we need to ban gas
stoves I guess and so but she's walking
in she's got her celebrity husband whose
Name Escapes me he's wearing a tuxedo
and then she has her slaves in the
background carrying the trail of her
dress and so much for the fourth estate
and so much for speaking on behalf of
the little guy and speaking truth to
power there were other celebrities too
there was that gal who Kanye West
briefly dated there were some other
people Vander or something Vanderpump is
that a name of a celebrity I don't know
I'm checked out I don't deal with this
pop culture because it's so desiccated
and shallow and absurd but the White
House Correspondents who were supposed
to be the most grounded people in our
media they're paling around with all
these guys Julia Fox I do remember her
name she was the one who who dated Kanye
West and then do you know the the most
absurd aspect of all about the White
House Correspondents association dinner
this is the part
that greats on me the most
it's not that they want their fancy
dinner with all their celebrities to
hobnob around and not oppose the
establishment but be part of the
establishment that I've come to expect
the part that grates on me the most
about the White House Correspondents
association dinner
is that they refer to it as nerd prom
nerd prom which implies that these
people are knowledgeable and intelligent
which are two adjectives that I don't
think you could say describe the
Washington DC press course certainly not
the White House Press Corps
nerd prom
a lot of people don't use nerd in this
way anymore this is still the primary
definition of nerd though
some people think nerd just means you're
really hyper enthusiastic and focused on
some niche subject matter
but you know it does imply intelligence
I couldn't remember if I was just going
crazy so I looked it up in
Merriam-Webster and it says primary
definition
a person devoted to intellectual
academic or technical Pursuits or
interests
does that Define Washington D.C journals
to you the people who cover the White
House no not at all
wood that it did there have been times
when when journalists have been
uh associated with intelligence with
knowledge in a particular subject area
that's gone
that's gone the journals in the liberal
media establishment which attends this
dinner they are much less informed on
these issues
they take these sorts of issues much
less seriously than the average person
on the street right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles hiring used to
be really hard you'd post your job on
multiple sites you'd hope the right
people would see it and then you'd wait
for them to apply same goes for finding
a job you upload your resume to every
job posting site comb through
never-ending lists of jobs trying to
find the right position for you zip
recruiter is the best place to find the
right position or if you're an employer
the right person to join your team head
on over to ziprecruiter.com Knowles try
it for free ZIP recruiters matching
technology excels at finding the most
qualified candidates for a wide range of
roles if you see a candidate you like
you can easily send them a personal
invitation so they're more likely to
apply it also gives you a Competitive
Edge against other employers who may
also be interested in that candidate
their user-friendly dashboard makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates all from one place four out
of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day see for yourself go
to ziprecruiter.com
to try ZipRecruiter for free that is
ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter smartest way to hire we'll
be Goldberg on The View
has just come out to scold Christians
because
Christians don't want to trans the kids
and whoopee
is convinced
that the Bible is very very clear about
how we should trans the kids
[Applause]
you're telling me that as a parent I
don't I'm not smart enough to decide if
my child and I need to have gender
affirming our doctors are not involved
what is going so I can't my I can't
decide what my kid reads I can't decide
for my child what my child says is going
on you're telling me your beliefs your
and they keep saying it and I keep
saying what Bible are you reading yeah
because God was really clear very clear
God was really clear that we need to
trans the kids and have the kids read
gay porn in schools so says Whoopi
Goldberg
I love too she focuses on she says these
parents these parents aren't even able
to show their decide what their kids are
going to read in schools
which by the way the whole issue over
the gay porn in the schools right now is
that parents don't want their kids to be
exposed to gay porn in schools it's the
it's the teachers and the weirdos and
The ideologues Who want the kids to read
gay porn in schools the parents are
saying please don't do that and the libs
are coming in and saying parents don't
have that right and Whoopi flips it and
she says parents should be able to to
teach their kids gay porn
but then of course you you run up
against this issue which is there's only
one book that you're not allowed to read
in schools
there's only one book that our Supreme
Court has said you're not allowed to be
taught in schools that of course would
be the Bible which Whoopi says that
she's quoting
it would seem likely to me that Whoopi
Goldberg has not read the Bible I know
the Bible does not say we ought to trans
the kids the point I want to make on it
is actually has nothing to do with
transiting the kids or Whoopi Goldberg
the point I want to make on it is that
line she says
she says it's so clear the Bible is very
clear
when someone says
the Bible is very clear
without any other context
you should be very skeptical of whatever
follows
wise people Avail themselves of History
so in in the modern world we just take
one sentence and we say well there's no
other context matters as dairy Dawes
said there is no outside text so it
doesn't matter what we know about the
author or the time in which he lived or
the works that he's referring to or the
great conversation that's taking place
over the course of history no all that
matters is the words on the page and
then whatever interpretation I want to
foist upon the words that's how modern
people view things and it's not just on
the left even some people who would
consider themselves more Centrist or
even right-wing will do that
especially when it comes to the Bible
but we don't have to do that that's a
very liberal modern approach
conservatives can Avail ourselves of the
wisdom of the ages
because our own stock of reason is
relatively paltry
even even those of us speaking and
listening to the show right now who I
know were definitely probably a couple
notches above
the people who attend the White House
correspondence association dinner in
terms of understanding and wisdom and
overall handsomeness I know but believe
it or not even we
don't know very much about very much and
so it's prudent to Avail ourselves of
the wisdom of the ages and so if Whoopi
had said okay I read somewhere in the
Bible that we should trans the kids I
don't know what verse I saw that in but
let's let's look at the history of the
church
is the church ever taught that it's good
to trans the kids no oh okay so where
did I get that idea what is more likely
that every Christian that ever came
before me including all the great
doctors of the church Saint Thomas
Aquinas Saint Augustine all that they
were all wrong and I dot doctor of the
church Whoopi Goldberg am right or that
I got it wrong what's more likely
obviously the latter that
that segment is going to give you a lot
to think about it's giving me a lot to
think about even hearing it again wow
such Insight if you want all of that
Insight you've got to ring the bell
click the thing do the doodad subscribe
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign